hi there steve here it's a sunny day
again
monday morning here in palm springs
i have on my t-shirt
master and margarita t-shirt that was
given to me
by a member from link who is also
a
professional golfer
elliot and yesterday he invited my wife
and i to
watch the
professional golf tournament that was on
here
in la quinta
and we had a wonderful day i really
enjoyed it
he picked up this t-shirt in victoria bc
at the bookstore
uh it just kind of reminds me of how i
mentioned the other day this whole
polyglot community people who study
languages they interact in different
ways they help each other
before i get going today by the way i'm
going to talk about immersion i'm going
to talk about immersion because ollie
richards who is a member of our polyglot
community
uh put out a video which said that
immersion doesn't work
and of course i had a video
one or two back where i said immersion
is the only way to go so i'm going to
talk about
our different perspectives on immersion
uh before i do that though i want to
announce something that i have already
put up on twitter and facebook which is
a bit of a
event that we're doing at link
where we're asking people to
tell me
if they had a 30-minute skype coaching
session with me
what would they want me to
explain or tell them or what would they
want to talk to me about
and uh the thing is yeah just put that
in a comment here under this video if i
had a 30 minute coaching session with
steve i would want him to talk about
this or i want would want him to help me
with this and we can talk about language
learning the
all these comments
on youtube on
twitter on facebook will be put into a
hat
and we will draw and the winner will
have a 30 a minute session with me maybe
if this works out well uh i might put
the discussion or parts of it up on uh
here on my youtube channel
and we might even do it again so um yeah
please let us know
what you would like to talk about if you
could have a chat with me about language
learning now getting back to this ollie
richards steve kaufman polyglots debate
so lo and behold
i follow different people on twitter
including ollie richards ollie richards
by the way is a great guy an excellent
polyglot speaks a variety of languages
from cantonese to arabic to spanish to
portuguese to french you name it
very helpful person very much involved
in the montreal polyglot conference and
the kind of guy
who's always willing to help other
people
as well as being good polyglot
so lo and behold here's this thing in
polish and again how the whole polyglot
community works oblong
in other words here you have pardon me
my rusty polish
but this fellow jensen
jensic marieski
said he or her that two polyglots
disagree with each other uh ollie says
um immersion is good the bad brother and
steve says it's good so
let's get to the heart of the matter
immersion you can where polygon many
polygons disagree about the edges of how
you learn a language there's very little
disagreement about certain points first
point is you can only get the language
through a lot of input
that's the crash in theory
because you don't have the language
inside you you have to bring the
language from those people who know the
language or from sources of the language
in order to get it into your brain and
you have to do it massively because
only that way is your brain going to get
used to the new language
so
ollie makes the point in his video
that you know you can't just ex you
can't just go to
kazakhstan maybe that's not a good
example but
you can't go to a place where just let
that ring go to a place and hear the
language around you or spend hours and
hours
watching television and hope that
somehow magically the language is going
to enter your brain it doesn't work that
way
so that's where we move from just
immersion to comprehensible input and
only by the way i can leave a link to
ali's video so ali says the issue the
key issue is that that
input has to be comprehensible all he
says in his video that it's possible
that through massive tens of thousands
of hours of listening to the language
just surrounded by the language that
some of it's going to penetrate
undoubtedly it does but it's not very
efficient and efficiency is so important
in language learning because time is one
of the key elements so obviously
the more efficiently you learn the
better you learn the more you're
building on things that you know
the more quickly you're going to learn
the language and the more you're going
to enjoy the process so the input has to
be comprehensible so we're really
talking about comprehensible
immersion
now what makes the immersion
comprehensible
now there are people and oli makes
reference to this in his video and i've
heard stephen krashen say it and others
that you should have input that's only a
little bit difficult for you and this is
sometimes defined as being sort of you
know 95 percent of the words and only
five percent are new
that's where i disagree i think that
once you are in content where you know
95 of it it's already too easy for you
you aren't learning very much you have
to go through lots and lots of content
to acquire new words because the key
struggle in language learning is to
acquire new words
um i think that you know if you just
have a book with nothing else to help
you perhaps you have to deal with 95
known words but the fact of the matter
is when you start into a language you
know zero words so how do you get from
zero to knowing a hundred words a
thousand words ten thousand words twenty
thousand words the vast number of words
you need to know in order to become
fluent if you are constantly dealing
first of all you can't start with
ninety-five percent known words you're
starting with 100
uh
unknown words
so therefore we now get to what's
possible nowadays with modern technology
with online dictionaries with link
with with a different you know with
audio there's a number of different ways
that can
make
uh content that has 10 or 20 unknown
words which i consider to be a bit of a
sweet spot
uh i mean obviously you started 100
unknown words but
very quickly you can move to 50 40 30
because as we know the most common words
repeat very often so as you acquire just
in any content without even trying
you're going to acquire these most
common words fairly soon and so now you
move to about 30 unknown words and and
again as i say 20
15 20 is a sweet spot where it's not too
difficult and yet you're acquiring words
at a fairly uh you know
a quick pace
so
i use link other people can use other
methods but when i'm in link i can look
up every word i can hear the word in
text-to-speech i can save a phrase and
text-to-speech i can listen to it
all of these things are helping me deal
with content so i no longer have to be
limiting myself to you know just five
percent unknown words in order for that
content to be comprehensible
the word comprehensible is a bit strong
because i'm listening to arab arabic
lessons that i don't understand more
than 10 15 20 of them until i listened
to it the 10th or 15th or 20th time but
it's comprehensible to me in the sense
that i can make it comprehensible
eventually if i stay with it
and it's compelling to me because i'm
motivated to try to understand more of
it and i can read it again and look up
the words again and listen again so as i
do this over and over again i'm
acquiring lots of new words
if i were to rely only on five percent
uh you know unknown words it would take
me forever to accumulate the vocabulary
that i need
i should add that um
you know
again on the subject of the community we
live in
skype and youtube and people and
someone recommended to me that i should
get this book called manuel dacha
boderne
okay so i ordered it from france
and it's it's an okay book there's
nothing much wrong with it lots of
grammatical explanations that kind of go
over my head or
either point out things that i've
already noticed in the language like the
adjective always comes after the noun i
mean after a couple of stories you
notice that the adjective always comes
after the noun it needn't be pointed out
as a major point of grammar in my
opinion but it's fine
um and then it has text like this but
it's difficult for me to read
uh in the book so what i've been doing
is uh
writing now in
arabic
entering these lessons into link
and then
because i got
audio cds with it i've taken each of the
lesson audios and imported into links so
i now have these as lessons in link i
wish
publishers of language textbooks
would make their texts available
digitally to those people who buy if i
buy this text i should be able to go to
a website download the audio download
the text and import it into something
like link because then this comes alive
i can read i can listen to it text to
speech i can highlight phrases i can do
all those things so that this material
becomes comprehensible and the advantage
of going to another source is as i've
said before variety is very important so
as much as i enjoy the many stories uh
you need the brain needs repetition and
novelty so it's very refreshing for me
to go to another source like this and
also do the stories there so
i guess what i'm coming to is
immersion depends how you define it
i agree entirely with with ali that if
you just go if i were to go to egypt and
surround myself with arabic i wouldn't
learn much i would still have to go back
to my room and do some deliberate
learning with sort of managed immersion
immersion that not not say 95 known
words but maybe 70 80 or
content where i at least have the the
possibility to figure out
what it all means and on that basis
immersing yourself in
content and i guess this gets back to
the point that i made a couple of videos
ago and that is don't stay with very
simple material that's too easy
get yourself into something that's sort
of lower intermediate such as our mini
stories at link such as the material in
this book
i mean even the first lesson in this
book is not that much easier than the
many stories the language if you're
talking about anything significant
happening is going to be at a level
beyond this is a book and so you may as
well get into that but get into it with
the means of understanding what's there
in other words some kind of system like
link that's going to enable you to cope
with
20 30 percent unknown words and that to
me is the level at which you can
progress quickly in the language so
in summary i don't disagree with ollie
perhaps our definitions of
comprehensible input and and even the
definition that stephen crashing has is
a little different than mine but mine is
influenced by my experience of learning
at link and don't forget if you're
interested in having a discussion with
me about language learning and you would
like me to help you on something drop a
little comment here about what you would
like to have me uh you know talk to you
about in terms of language learning the
draw will be on february the 2nd and
thereafter we'll schedule the discussion
thank you for listening and bye for now
[Music]
you